Nếu kêu cơ cấp kinh hành phải chú đẩm trình khai giải pháp phòng ngừa,
chẳng ánh hưởng tiêu cược đến sả suốt kinhzoa ngờ đời sống nhân dân.
Trong đó, thực hành tích kiệp, sử dụng như liệu hiệu quả đưa xem là biển pháp quan trọng
nhằm cùng cộ án nền ngặng lượng của sai về giải hạt Việt Nam sẽ sĩ dựng trở lộ tổn thầy về công mứng
dự chữu mua như liệu và đẩy máy chuyển đổi năng lượng.
Đông thời khoán chiến tình thần này, thu tướng pháp mi chính đã chỉ đạo khuyến khí phát triển phương tiện điện
và hạt tân chạm xa để tân bước giả vụ thuận vào một nhập khẩu.
Nguyên đường đau chính phủ nhân mạnh, một tiêu suyên xuất là không để sây ra thiếu hột sáng sâu,
trong bất kiện hoàn kính nào.
Cuối tâm suy trí đa tăng trưởng kinh tế ở mất hai con số trong loa ngình không chảm y sấu,
và các năm tiếp theo.
Để thực hiện hiệu quả cái lợg số mùi bốn,
bố chính trị yêu cầu các quả trình năng theo sỏi xa diện biển thế giới,
lấy ngoài vần dụng các công cụ chính xách tại quả tiền tệ,
quá li ra và thương mạnh.
Công tắt thành chạy kìm chà đồ vị xoanh nghiệp đồng mối vài thông phân phối phải đưa tăng tương.
Khi quả xử li nghiêm các hành vi căm hàng, chủp lợi khoảng 1 lộ.
Mọi giá các bộ, mọi sao công thương và tài chính đưa ra những vụ.
Chua đạo ng làm việc mì cái đối tắc khu tế.
Hỗ trợ xoanh nghiệp trong nước tiếp cận môn công mồ định,
và phần thực hiện tháng lợi các mục tiêu phát triển kinh tệ giả hội bình vấn.